and this is episode 5 holy shit I think
this is strikes back disappearing so far
this is my favorite it has pretty much
every character and they all get a
pretty fair amount of time dedicated to
them there's a lot of twists and turns
shit starts to go down like shit's
getting real there surprises with all
sorts of characters there's a lot of
development for for a lot of them it's
just it's just a really fucking good
episode it's the one where a kingpin has
a girlfriend and she's fucking nuts like
him so it's great I love most yeah you
know and what I liked this episode sets
up so much that you think you know
what's gonna happen cuz you've seen that
a million other shows and throws in so
many good twists and turns I mean you're
even hearing like well I bet this is gay
ever and that's probably get out I gotta
do this and it's like they go do they
wrong sir yeah and all these other
twists in there but the one thing I kind
of do I said you know okay well she's
either dead or she's gonna be crazy too
and it's like oh she's crazy - that is
so much more interesting
yeah and the the show do cuz having read
the comics way back in the day I want to
make something clear you call me the
expert on there don't compared to you
yes oh so you're an expert I just say
you know more than I know you like first
episode there's something we reviewed it
I think you use the word expert not an
expert
I haven't read really any comics since
the way your main ID so but knowing what
I do know about daredevil I know the
characters so it's a testament to the
show that that whole dinner scene I
still was like where are they going with
this cuz I'm not a hundred percent sure
and that goes back to that previous
episode where he took the Russians head
off because when he says you know why
did you bring the gun why is it in your
purse like no well what I have got is
yeah what kind of yeah what kind of gun
is that in your purse
I choked like I couldn't breathe for a
second because I'm like oh my god is he
gonna kill her
like I know you
and knowing what I know I'm like I
wouldn't think so but at the same time I
was just like I don't know for sure
because this show just kind of feels
like it could do any fad battle that
earlier see that whole dinner scene was
both so uncomfortable but so engaging
and fascinating I kept pulling me in
like I just wanted to know more about
this guy at the same time I kind of
didn't want to know you know it's like
I'm legitimate kind of afraid of this
guy but I'm so intrigued by him I'm in
hilarious that like we have way less
courage than the woman going on the
dinner date oh he was great like he just
kept getting a he's like crazy yeah it's
like oh she is crazy
yeah no but that's the thing see that
sir it's not even America just that this
is I know what she wants to I mean when
she sees those explosions no it's just
like oh like you know she's on the same
page with him yeah Vanessa in the show
is a very interesting character and I
love you know I was talking earlier
about how this show runs on
juxtapositions this is a big one because
we're basically given there's like a
yin-yang going on as one set happens
with the heroes something else happens
with the villains and they offset each
other so in the case of daredevil Claire
is very much like that do you hear how
you sound do whatever it takes like I
don't know if I could fall in love with
something like that I don't know if you
should meanwhile you have the dinner
date scene right after that with the
fisca and Vanessa
where it's the exact opposite she's kind
of into it yeah and he of course you
know definitely wants her on board
so it's this interesting play between
these two sets of Carol says he knows
how to pick him a cake pan it's like of
all the people sure but she's kind of
pretty
maybe she's fucking psychotic and wants
to be like with me in my crime lord miss
and look and I love um I love when the
when the city explodes that American
Gothic moment
it's the two of them standing just one
there yeah if she's just like this and
they're both staring out and then it
does a reverse angle on that so you see
them from behind as if they were staring
at a painting the city's on fire it's
like they're looking at a work of art
exactly like how they they do look at
the work of art when they first met you
know an admiring just this great you
know and even when you say let me first
bed you know it makes me feel alone it's
like you can't get the idea yeah they
kind of are alone but they're alone
together
no one says I don't like to be in public
and this taps into that thing it's
everything about whom is control if he's
not in public he doesn't have control of
the situation
he wants to remake the city from the
ground up it's just manipulation
manipulation control control control he
just wants to control everything around
him and you see the fear in him
constantly which is so intrigued yeah
every time I see him I'm like I don't
know if I like the you know you see him
doing the business dealing sound
counting I don't know if I like the kind
of quivering almost afraid looks like
he's almost about to cry thing but it's
like you still see you know he just he's
got it kind of under control and through
all this and stuff it's like we know
where he is we got that you know he's at
now though he's well he's got it I've
seen some criticisms out there I've seen
people just like oh thank him because
like he looks worried or he's just like
acting weird and I like I want the the
ultimate kingpin who's just always got
it together and this and that the
scariest thing on the planet is somebody
who has fear but has learned to master
it and the the scariest thing on the
planet is a psychopath who has sphere
but his learn to master because that
fear helps drive them and that is this
guy yeah he has fear yeah he has this
but you can see him get it under control
and you know and the few times he
doesn't it doesn't manifest itself and
Owen scared like he's always got that
but he's always mastering that it
manifests itself and I'm gonna take her
motherfucking head off um that's scary
it's way scarier to me than some other
villains are just like are just
all-powerful like that it if I saw this
guy like if I also Krim
whatever and I saw this guy and we
talked like it that whatever at the taxi
place and stuff like that I mean I would
kind of be like I don't know I don't
know if I'd be on board with this guy
give him a chance but because he has
proven himself so much I would be like
okay this guy knows what he's doing it's
that there is something intimidating
about him that when he does have it
together like it's something about
d'Onofrio's performance he kind of just
stares through you like he just gets
this like he'll he'll look away and
he'll have those moments of fear but
then when he returns his gaze you just
feel like the heat from his eyes like
like burning a hole free you know what
the fear also shows I mean when he's
doing those dealings is that shows
bizarrely enough kind of dishonesty I
mean when he went to them is just like
you know I I killed him with you know my
car and stuff like that and I told him
at the man the masted and hopefully
that'll buy us some time I want to move
past this as quickly as possible and say
I mean there is sort of this strange
calculating way that's like you know yes
I know this is the situation and you
know I apologize for my lateness but you
know I think it is best if we stick on
this everything is the same everything
you know there's still served this
honesty to what he's doing well and
that's the scary thing about him is he's
a person who can use reason and logic
who that you could in theory reason with
but is also an insane psychotic that can
snap at any second that to me is just
way scarier
um but yeah you know and like at the
beginning this episode when they say
it's the man the mask who killed your
brother and stuff like that I mean I
thought I have this whole thing peg okay
they're gonna be chasing him down and
they're gonna be saying you're the one
who did it and he's guessing I didn't
kill your brother and he'd be like mayor
oh just like in the movie and uh but no
they pretty much III me okay the guy
still alive by the end but I mean like
he tells the people the truth he's like
but we gotta keep this secret from you
know Vladimir time it'll buy us time and
everything and then you see him kiss
rosario Dawson it's like well kids I'm
glad they sort of sped this up because
it's usually be about again half a
season later before they do is and then
in the exact same episode EES like she's
like I don't know if I can do this yeah
you probably should man it's just like
man we just sort of jumped there to like
every place I thought this way here you
go
tightly written yeah I mean it's like I
just so love it when they're like hey
you thought we were gonna do this so
you've seen a million other shows no
we're gonna throw you something
different we're gonna throw a nice spin
on you think the woman is you know
probably gonna be in danger though one
date again but it's like you know no
she's totally on board and so there's
like so many of the black guy know she
say to you you think he's gonna be you
know he's gonna betray and he said the
righteous i but no no he he was paid off
he's you know got all that figured out
too
the thing about Vanessa too like you
said she's totally on board the other
thing I like about her is she's smart
like she says like did you really think
I didn't know what you do yeah these
times you're amazing this hatered almost
from the beginning yeah when you say
this character can't be so dumb or when
they walk into the the law firm and
she's like oh I will have this sale
before the elevator comes down okay
again all these characters you thinking
like they can't possibly be this dumb
and they're not and I think he gets off
on it to the fact that she's smart if
you notice something the three people he
has the best interaction with so far
Vanessa and I think he gets off on her
intelligence
Wesley which is not a sexual
relationship but let's be honest they're
like kind of like a there's a little
wave some sums yeah I love Beverly
it's a Frodo it's a Frodo Sam like
British officer and his like lieutenant
kind of like our assistant you know
we've seen that a lot from you know Lex
Luthor hasn't had his in the animated
series and then I also Zanna toes and
gargoyle yeah so it's like that those
people that are so on the same page yeah
actual yeah it's they are definitely
going above and beyond call of duty yeah
and the other one is lady gal like if
you noticed yeah
meets lady gal with such respect and you
it's very clear early on that Lady Gao
is a step above the rest of them yeah
like Japanese guy is mysterious but
Russians are kind of dumb Leland's just
a word the way she holds herself yeah
everything she just yeah is just very
business but you get this idea that lady
GAO it's like there's a real brain here
like and he seems to be attracted to
these brains in this operation whether
it's you know love life business life
friends he referred to Wesley as his
friend so yeah I think he gets off of it
like that because further reason is
attracted to her well and yeah and see I
think that's what makes them so
interesting to again is that it is that
you know it's not just for advantage
there's a legit respect for these people
that have just worked so hard and stayed
us several steps ahead of the game
because that's what you want to do too
and that's what he admires he wants to
see so I got me these people but I also
really admired when I think after a
while too there may be just the very
basic depression of God I'm surrounded
by idiots like because he's running a
bunch of idiots like you could there's a
reason the Russians go first yeah like
he's got them pegged as like he says it
was canons I don't know what they're
doing so yeah oh foggy and Karen page
yeah no they got nice nice campus for
you going on there like I'm what I like
him so much more when he's not doing the
you know dude
well chill I like it when he's smart I
like a waste charismatic I like it when
he's you know I I don't like when he's
the doofus that much I mean except when
he's doing the romantic stuff at least
he kind of plays off it well you know
what can I do I'm cabin doofus like but
not quite bad romantic comedy you do
fish you know yeah it's believable
enough it's not something like he's the
most fun person well this was a great
episode for foggy because not only did
we have the date scene but the scene
where he tells Marcy off that's why yeah
like he just say he just shut her down
and it's like hello lawyer in the
business like oh I should say like
earlier when you were asking you know
they're just starting out and I was
confused this episode was the reason
because I was thinking back to that I
remembered this episode is like did he
work at that from first I forgot he had
only into
yeah with man and then they went did
their own things you know the one thing
is Mike is there's a great shot where
they get the blind guy in the car and
the camera sort of shifts around and
there it's a sort of paranormal activity
shot it's like there's daredevil goes by
the circle tried again and he's gone and
stuff like that and I do I see we're
singing about Batman because I've seen
to myself god I love this character
I just wish when I saw that's like I
can't wish that was Batman there cuz
don't get me wrong like he's so cool and
I'm only talking about the design I wish
there's something as cool as Batman with
the long years and the cape and stuff
standing there but we still got the
black mask and even when he evolves to
whatever the red mask with the little
horns and stuff it's still not that
great a couple might be it's like it
could be a great character but still not
that phenomena costume I'd be very
curious in a bizarro universe if DC did
spider-man and Marvel did Batman because
this to be just again like when they
think out of the box it gets really
incredible like the shows that got
running now or complete opposites of
what's going on in the movies I think
it's more interesting yeah so yeah I
love this one I love it just throwing so
many good twists only good developments
about the characters shits going down
it's not taking forever to get stuff go
Amy there's at four huge buildings
pretty much blew up you know and they
were watching it it was visually
interesting as well and it's the you
know it was the Daggett plan from Batman
yet yeah sure might be a victory to blow
up Crime Alley and I'm like oh it's bad
yeah I'm not saying it was a direct
ripoff I just like I had flashbacks at
episode I was like Oh blow up a poor
neighborhood with people still in it
kind of douchey hey Vanessa thinks it's
hot and the last thing I'll say is that
you know I was really having issue that
anytime he would cut a guy I would just
be like man does that just I mean I know
he's like on the edge of stuff of that
that does not seem superhero II by any
and that's not maybe The Punisher would
do like just a total psychopath but this
conversation that she had with him now I
can kind of see where it's playing in
because it's even with Batman really
like I think in every
okay I haven't seen every incarnation
but like the movie and TV show
incarnations of Batman they would say
he's walking the line and I'm like just
kind of the vigilante and that he would
kind of you know rough people up or
whatever no I can see him knowledge
separate let's separate a couple worlds
here Nolan films yes that was that was
the thing that I found it was kind of
interesting how they did it but it
definitely was not kind of the Batman I
wanted the animated series is a little
more like the noir comics after they
softened it a bit not the goofy sort of
but definitely softened kind of noir the
Burton films though like the early
without those first two famine and
Batman Returns he's like over the line
he'll just kill criminals if he wants
if fucking Joey Bob's off a building on
a movie star well that that's what they
claim oh come on
fed for probably didn't okay okay no
they took a walk off a roof no but
here's the thing like even even with
tradition of superhero like Luke
Skywalker shoots tour tubers we're
shooting at him you kind of get it
there's something about cutting a guy
inside a torture it is torture
oh yeah no okay I see what you mean
there's definitely more it's this
superheroes way more torture II know but
any incarnation of Batman we see it may
be that no but I will say that but
that's always where I thing like that's
like walking the line when you're doing
this stuff but you know you're doing for
a good cause but like it's fucking
torture and you know I'm like yeah well
no but that's what I really like we're
in this one what she's saying I don't
think I can be in love with a guy who is
so close to becoming what he's fighting
in this I see it with Batman it's always
like even though I understand the
arguments that they serve make it so you
don't really feel it's like crime
fighter you get it's like I legitimately
get uncomfortable whenever he's like
interrogating a guy I mean and but you
find out that is kind of the point that
is the purpose of I guess my thing is
it's a maybe I'm just psychotic I just
it's kind of always what I kind of
wanted at a Badman which is we kind of
dress it up and try to pretend it's not
crazy and fascist and like now Batman
particularly post Nolan like it smell
like Hut's just about justice and he's
got rules this rules bad and I'm just
like if
you're gonna be a crazy-ass vigilante
just go full fashion like this this guy
doesn't care and I think it kind of
makes it more in I shouldn't say that he
does care but it makes it more
interesting because he has to grapple
with that whereas the the Nolan Batman
in particular was so bound by these
rules well no hold on I was arc nice
young Dark Knight yeah that's why I was
gonna say he clearly stepped over a line
but oh yeah it's like very no you know
it's bad intellectual sort of lectures
are a rule that's like the NSA like you
know it's like I might be violating
people's you know Rights by listening in
on their cell phones I'm like okay like
there's a difference between that which
I don't agree with either and I'm gonna
cut you if you don't tell me we're very
much against what goes on in our own
frickin government you know with spying
on us very much against it but yeah
there's there there are different
degrees difference between that like
spying on the conversation and like I'm
gonna shove a knife in your trigeminal
nerve and just dig into YouTube because
like that's what every single fight it's
the same thing it's like tell me what I
wanna know
know like tell me tell me and then make
it look like it hurts yeah so I mean
it's there's a huge difference it's like
listening to my phone's you know what
it's Batman I'm sure he's not gonna be
like oh I'm gonna find you know it's
he's gonna stop the Joker something like
it really seems to be walking that line
it's the difference between spying on
people with their cell phones and
waterboarding they're both really bad
but they're two different things yeah
and with with this like I said it's like
if that may waterboard some I'd be like
holy shit this guy's like really no no
this doesn't seem right we're a base
listening to a phone it's like okay yeah
it's not right but it's fucking Batman
you know come on we trust him with this
it's like again it's it's fucking to it
sure it's you're crazy it's one of the
more crazy superheroes I've seen
probably since the Keaton day but they
definitely show that you you definitely
see Y it you see this world and the
other thing I really like we talk about
dumb characters doing dumb things do you
think it's like cuz the last episode guy
you know he bails his eye on a spike
just for saying the guy's name so
this guy says I'm like oh well there was
all that build-up in suspense later but
no become so like your turn
yeah you should pass are on the payroll
got it okay that that's perfect cuz I'm
thinking to myself man we just let that
but I know you spun it around and it was
all part of your plan and I said and
love that they've set up so well how
difficult this is gonna be for Murdock
to and Murdock the end friends that
should be a sitcom uh to do this and
what the stakes are like when when Karen
and Ben and foggy and why am i blank
Cantor named Claire and Murdock like
these are the stakes that every single
thing is stacked against you the cops
you got the various mob so you know
you've got politicians like on the
payroll in this and that like you know
finance ears even the good people you
know like you saw with the the wife of a
guy who died mhm you suddenly yeah I'm
just gonna take this element and it's
it's kind of like with this world they
created it's like even though you may
not agree with it's like you see why you
just see why this environment they
created is just so creepy and disturbing
I mean it's right up there with like any
you know Breaking Bad or Game of Thrones
environment where you're just like oh my
god you just feel so alone and it just
makes you know what Murdoch has to go up
against even bigger and grander and it
also I'm not necessarily justify it
makes you understand why he does these
terrible things like towards and I will
give credit to DC and Nolan this is what
made Dark Knight work like it was that
sense of dread and Dark Knight that
drove me like nuts up the wall in like a
good way of just like oh my god there's
police on the payroll the Joker has
access to all of these things here
you've got the Mafia it's like no matter
what Batman had seem to do he always
just kind of seemed fucked and like
that's something that this I think I
don't know if it intentionally borrowed
from the Nolan films but something that
it grasps but it how to do that just as
whether it doesn't go Dark Knight Rises
where he's constantly like fucked idiot
every other turn it's like this guy is
making
advances and he's adapting is trying to
learn but at what cost you know we're in
Dark Knight Rises he just you know dumb
turn after dumped her after dumb turn
we're here this guy who's actually like
yeah sometimes they're ahead but then
he'll sort of catch up to I mean he's
obviously getting on their nerves he's
obviously I think enough time as it has
threat people don't bring up Dark Knight
Rises as the great Batman movie out of
that
I'll come out they'll come out oh I hate
that movie as much as you do but I still
will ready Dark Knight Batman Begins no
but there's some people that don't see
why you know I necessarily don't like
the movie and I'm just like just when
you see it done well and you see it dumb
like me you just admire this guy but at
the same time you're so on the fence
with him too with some of the stuff he's
doing it's like this is what I wanted to
see in Dark Knight Rises and here it's
being done that's why I think it's def
just complaining about what's done wrong
we should cheer when it's done right so
yeah that's a great episode one prime
prime my favorite so far I uh I hope
they get even better cuz yeah I'm
excited man see you the next one there
it is